how come raise my spear to pass so this
demo just came out made by the I don't
know the one who made Silent Hill and it
looks very interesting I don't know much
about it but I already know I want to
play with you Bruce watch out the gap in
the door it's a separate reality the
only me is me
are you sure they only use you oh you
were [ __ ] with me right now
what is this that supposed to mean is
that a [ __ ] bog god I hate cockroaches
is there a phase in its but the hell is
over die ok I guess the game wants me to
go here huh oh the graphics is amazing
is that radio it's almost midnight huh
ok then spider way
oh nice father shot him to his
six-year-old daughter had the good sense
to hide in the bathroom but reports
suggest he lured her out by telling her
it was just a game the girl was shot
once in the chest from point-blank range
the mother who was shot in the stomach
was pregnant at the talk come on
police arriving on scene after neighbors
called 911 found the father in his car
listening to the radio several days
before the murders neighbors say they
heard the father repeating a sequence of
numbers in a loud voice they said it was
like he was chanting some strange spell
this is real there was another family
shot to death in the same state last
month and in December last year a man
used a rifle and meat cleaver to murder
his entire family in each case the
perpetrators were fathers State Police
say this string of domestic homicides
appears unrelated though it could be
part of a larger trend such as
employment childcare and other social
issues facing the average of a family
that is so [ __ ] on what is wrong with
you
what isn't this that it is the same
corridor what is this am I stuck in a
loop am I stuck in the loop am I stuck
in the loop am I stuck in the loop am i
stuck in a loop am i sorry Oh what the
hell I like that interior very cool
design game what is that [ __ ] noise
shut up blam what I'm not stuck in the
loop
I miss oh hell no girl I ain't going
there alright let me go cockroach hello
what is happening here and what kind of
oddly Swedish like fifties no forties
maybe I don't know I don't know if
Swedish culture main like when my
parents were young what is this
hello can I go out is it really we had
game rez I don't know what's going on
this is very confusing for me they won't
let me go maybe I should check out over
here
we're going back why is is this time man
planned you had an alcohol problem Jesus
how much did you drink plant
don't even bother answering me you [ __ ]
I don't understand what the door is open
now that is three [ __ ] PE can we go
to oh what a big surprise it hello what
is that noise huh we're good to go
hello I said anybody bag okay cry all
you want Dora I am NOT gonna go in yeah
damn I got goose nips like it's nobody's
business right now
[ __ ] creepy man Jesus they really
know subtle horror those Japanese
[ __ ] sorry hello don't do that again
please oh hell no oh no okay
just breathe we can go back yep I'm sure
this will work I'm like 99% sure if this
doesn't work I will not do anything yep
that's what I meant to say all along
keep being amazed by the graphics it
feels so real where do you want me to go
then
someone is obviously messing with me
here I'm sorry mate but you married a
man you got tricked I mean maybe that's
what he wanted all along but I'm just
saying that it's not a woman what what
the [ __ ] did that door just I
okay Oh God oh no I'm I am NOT going
there oh my god are you serious
Oh God Oh
oh [ __ ] Oh
hello is anyone in there Snoop Dogg what
deaf no [ __ ] way
okay that's cool
didn't want to go there anyway oh that's
great
I'm happy for you man oh man I don't
know whatever she look like the girl in
the picture
oh god is she crying don't know hi don't
don't cry oh god sorry hello
oh god okay it's right it's crying oh no
did oh god they're everywhere
don't [ __ ] with me I know karate now I
don't but they don't know okay so far so
boy number ChaCha's so far so bleh no
you don't speak Spanish and means so far
Oh God we're fun times to take that back
I take it back
I repelled it that's not what I got
oh the flashlight okay cool
don't kill me
Oh God oh girl I'd rather look at that
calc
I mean cockroach then I mean what the
[ __ ]
who came up with this what is wrong with
bball what let me go I'm not I don't
want to be stuck in there in here with
that thing
my name is Robert I don't care what your
name is
let me go hey how you doing
look at me flap my boobies fire I've got
Rubert please don't don't try to burn
you are you a space alien like I don't
understand you [ __ ] you can attract the
lady
Oh
all right everybody why did you do that
I'm worried like I'm gonna steer in the
mirror back oh hell no see we're never
safe never oh my god oh my god this game
is [ __ ] off baby alien fetuses I've
seen it all now thank you very much
radio is playing yeah what's with it
what's for the time and five sight now
it's very spooky don't touch that dial
now we're just getting started the trees
delightful and shine
I don't trust have water any anyways
don't worry mining - what is that sound
no no oh my god oh my god oh god what
happened
I didn't mean to poke her eye out
I swear to god it wasn't me oh my god
she's even prettier now oh I'm going
backwards I don't [ __ ] trust these
[ __ ] Shay Oh God
[ __ ] that [ __ ] - oh god it's a baby
making noise Rubert I'm sorry I'm sorry
okay please quick please oh my god
what's he whined jab bloody feet dance
ballet what was my pure little hockey
net
oh my scared Edgar oh my god what is
wrong with people you did this you did
this
uh-oh minecraft man my ball is just
subtracted inside my body I am now
boneless I mean I am now but oh god damn
what what do you want that's actually
kind of nice I think will work did you
say something what is that a cat box
still the weird red mic guys Lewbert
Lewbert
please please come okay Lewbert I'm here
to help
I know you have a great talent I'm
shaking boobies but I need you to stop
crying oh it's not ruber just crying
it's my daughter oh oh come on that's
[ __ ] up it's got a fridge or what is
it okay I didn't I didn't hear anything
just gonna keep walking
yep that's great this [ __ ] game is
[ __ ] up man and not in a good way
all the bad race well I don't know Bert
what is he don't trust the tap water not
trusting you not trusting you
hey girl it's gonna be okay girl there
we go it works every time I can hear
them calling to me from somewhere coming
from the phone oh my god it change it
change what is that was a hell oh hell
she hear me screams from hell
oh my god Oh God
he's laughing it was laughing alright we
did burst that's my high five without
hands that was a little weird
before the diminishes notice failure the
engrossed so to tell you from to them it
is VDC
know what the [ __ ] it's Swedish how do
you know this my face is melting right
now soon that gates to new dimension
will open - sir for a
oh my god that is so [ __ ] up I got
goose nips even when I don't have own my
nips that's what we're talking about
right now bus we just [ __ ] [ __ ] ever
what I'm a super speed bunny well that's
the only plus I've ever had in this game
am I supposed to go through like a fast
I am
oh yeah that's not creepy at all is it I
do that [ __ ] too when I'm bored on
Saturdays
just kidding I'm unconscious usually Oh
God
oh it's making me drunk just to look at
Rudolph
Rubin I mean whatever your name is I
cared for you a lot so where did you go
where'd you go my little and seems like
it's been forever
well what's that can i oh my god oh this
is creepy man see anything why do I feel
like a such a perm oh why why oh no
turning back now
are we is it is it a fad it's the bad
man gone now look through there there we
are thank God we made it out alive never
been so happy we out of a loop before
but I still think we're in it so I'm not
celebration yet if you know what I'm
saying I think God thank you so much
oh it's 12:00 now Jesus I'm late for
supper
wait why I'm just late okay what goes on
in here so doric hello River it is
nowhere to be found I don't trust you
the man told me not to trust you though
I'm gonna I'm gonna trust you that's a
song I wrote literally two seconds ago
okay what was that what the [ __ ] was I
I'm not a robot
but not been acting tough lately and I
be not smoking a lot at cigarettes you
see oh god stop it I'm not a robot
I got damnit plot twist I'm a robot I
knew it
what is it why can you stop it please
I'm busy looking at yarn 4 6 3 2 0 4 8 6
3 ok
whose same name
of God
what I'll call later did you break my
playstation this game bros I don't I
can't I can
there's a restarting everything gross I
don't even know anymore what a thief
what is abuse what we are we starting
again did I fail
hello I have my flashlight
23:59
what does it all mean what did it's
darker than ever now Oh God ooh burn it
Rupert it's still here shaking them
titties like it's nobody's business nice
and still not trusting the water tap
water what I wasn't cheating what's
going on here
Oh God no stop crying oh my god you win
it's not like happy and crying at the
same time it's weirdest thing ever a lot
of pills here so many [ __ ] pills
it's 12 now again am I supposed to find
all the peace sense it's not a piece
what who did that laughs you think this
is funny
you think this is a game but I tell you
boy it's not what the [ __ ] is that life
stop it
you don't know me
what hello
did we do it come on Oh dad was such a
drag every day he'd eat the same kind of
food dress the same sit in front of the
same kind of games hey what's wrong with
it yeah it was just that kind of guy but
then one day he goes and kills us all
god damn it dad he couldn't even be
original about the way he did it I'm not
complaining I was dying of boredom
anyway what the [ __ ] but guess what I
will be coming back and I'm bringing my
new toys with me oh god damn eh what is
this oh my god what we made an outer
I'm stayin light up
I'm a shoe is that it
silent Hills shoe silent you see Okajima
where are we this looks American
you know way are they working together
that's awesome
holy Sh a barrel barrel what are you
doing in my game Darrel a goddamn Norman
Reedus that his name a cop what what oh
yeah it's back baby
all those shitty Western remakes
oh my god what happened so this was the
silent hill's playable teeth sir silent
silent hill's
I guess so how that's how they got the
IP bag diving bears on it because you
must introductions oh my god this game
is a teaser it has no direct relation to
that okay but damn was it a good tea sir
that [ __ ] ending took me forever holy
[ __ ] I don't even know what I did I
don't know what I feel about Daryl being
in there it's like another generic main
character in the horror game like
generic bad bad ice I don't know I was
hoping for something different that
makes me a little bummed that we'll see
I'm excited for the game at least hope
people has enjoyed this video if you did
thank you for leaving it like and thanks
for hanging out with me today Bruce
that's all for me for now
stay awesome brows bro